-Our next guest is
a best-selling author
and Oscar-winning screenwriter
whose books include
"A Prayer For Owen Meany,"
"The World According to Garp,"
"The Hotel New Hampshire,"
and "Cider House Rules."
His 15th novel,
"The Last Chairlift,"
is out now.
Please welcome to the show
John Irving, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, John.
I'm so honored to have you here.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Now, this is your 15th book.
You're a prolific writer.
This is 900 pages.
This is the longest one.
Did you know when you set out?
-I sincerely hope
it's the longest one.
And I'm almost certain
that's the longest one.
-Yeah, you're not
going to beat this record?
-No. There's only short trains
in the station.
That's it.
-When you had the idea,
did you know this was
going to be the long one?
-I knew it would be long.
I didn't know it would be my
longest or longer --
forgive me --
than "Bleak House,"
almost as long as
"David Copperfield."
I didn't know
it would be that long.
But when you follow the lives of
the main characters'
extended family --
his cousin, her girlfriend,
his mother,
her girlfriend,
and the stepfather,
who transitions to female --
you have a lot of lives
to follow.
-Yeah.
-And it's my intention
to take each of those
characters to an ending.
-You -- I think a lot of
writers begin with
an idea of how
a book should start.
I've heard you say
you like to begin knowing
what the ending is going to be.
Have you always found
that reverse engineering to be
the right approach
for you, creatively?
-Always, yes, but I needed to
write four books
before I realized
it wasn't going to change.
I needed to realize
that there wasn't something
really wrong with me.
It's that I see endings first.
I don't have the confidence
to begin a novel
unless I'm writing toward
an ending that I have foreseen,
that is, in my mind,
predetermined.
And that's --
It's just always been that way.
-Well, certainly as a reader,
I appreciate when
that moment, sometimes of dread,
when you realize an author
might not know
where this was going.
And so I like when you --
the confidence when
you're reading,
you know, again, an author
that you have
a relationship with.
Being in safe hands
is a nice feeling.
You sort of mentioned
a lot of the characters,
and maybe people
picked up on it,
but the protagonist
is a straight white male
surrounded by LGBTQ characters.
Is this -- Was it a plan of
yours to write about
his perspective of that world
or to make him sort of
the outsider
amongst that group?
-It was certainly my intention
to make him the odd guy out,
to make him the queer
member of the family,
queer in the sense of strange
and not up to speed.
And he is the slowest member of
his extended family.
He's learning from
all the rest of these people.
And I don't think it will be
a surprise to anyone
that he's also,
as the only straight guy,
the most badly behaved sexually.
-Yeah. You've been writing about
sexual and gender politics
for a very long time.
I feel like,
you know, perhaps the --
you know,
the take on those topics
from your readership
has changed.
Has it made it easier
to write about,
has it made it harder
more satisfying to write about?
-It's made it depressing
that it hasn't gone away.
-The issues?
-Yeah.
I remember, when I was starting
"The World According to Garp,"
that I was even naive enough
to imagine that a novel
about these extremes of
sexual intolerance,
these extremes of sexual hatred,
I honestly thought
the novel was
in danger of being passé,
or out of date,
before I published it.
-You -- Another book of yours,
"Cider House Rules,"
which took place in the '40s
and was sort of a book
about what would happen if
abortion was illegal,
is it also shocking to you
that we haven't --
or it seems as though maybe
we moved past it
and now maybe we're moving back?
-Well, we sure are moving back.
I remember, at the time,
some of my friends
thought it was quaint that I was
writing an "historical novel"
about that time when abortion
was unsafe and illegal.
And what they meant was,
"Now that we have Roe v. Wade,
now that it's secure."
Well, I wrote that novel
intentionally as a warning,
because there were
already the voices in --
The anti-abortion zealots
were already there,
and this was my way of saying,
"Everything that happens
in this story
can only happen at a time
when this procedure
is unsafe and illegal.
Do you really
want to go back there?"
And it doesn't make me
feel prescient.
I'm not prescient.
I'm really bad
at guessing the future.
But I've also been really bad at
underestimating the pushback
against everything progressive
in women's rights
and LGBTQ rights.
I underestimate that
there's going to be a pushback.
-Yeah.
Progress is not permanent.
-And that the pushback
doesn't go away.
-Yeah. This is really special to
have you here tonight.
I grew up reading your books.
My mom is your biggest fan.
She came to the show tonight.
She went in your dressing room
beforehand with me.
Overall, how do you think
she behaved?
[ Laughter ]
-I thought her behavior
was exemplary.
I was very happy to meet her.
-Well, you have
not sacrificed your role
as her favorite living author.
You clinched it.
You clinched it right there.
John Irving, everybody.
"The Last Chairlift"
is available now
wherever you buy your books,
and please support local
and independent bookstores.
We'll be right back with music
from Rina Sawayama.